un acto de omisión, de superficialidad,
el pecado de la ira, de la autocompasión,
un intento de complacer a la gente, una falta de coraje.
Adán 1 se construye al construir tus fortalezas.
Adán 2 se construye superando debilidades.
Mira hacia tu interior, encuentra el pecado que hayas
cometido una y otra vez a lo largo de tu vida,
tu pecado típico
del cual surgen otros pecados,
y pelea y lucha contra ese pecado,
y de esa lucha, de ese sufrimiento
se construye la profundidad de carácter.
Y generalmente no se nos enseña a reconocer
el pecado en nosotros mismos,
nuestra cultura no nos enseña
a luchar contra él,
cómo enfrentarlo, y cómo combatirlo.
Vivimos en una cultura con una mentalidad de Adán 1
en donde no podemos hacer nada sobre Adán 2.
Finalmente, Reinhold Niebuhr
resumió la confrontación, la vida al máximo
de Adán 1 y Adán 2, de la siguiente manera:
"Nada que valga la pena hacer se puede lograr en toda una vida;
por lo cual nos debe salvar la esperanza.
Nada que sea verdad o bello o bueno
tiene sentido en el contexto inmediato de la historia;
por lo tanto nos debe salvar la fe.
Nada de lo que hagamos, sin importar cuán virtuoso sea, se logra solo;
por lo tanto, nos debe salvar el amor.
Ningún acto virtuoso es tan virtuoso
desde el punto de vista de nuestro amigo o enemigo como lo es desde el nuestro.
Por lo tanto, nos debe salvar esa forma final de amor,
que es el perdón".
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)